ciao buongiorno a tutti oggi parlo di
software per computer e parlo del filone
in particolare che è il finale dell'open
source
lo faccio perché secondo me è importante
parlare di questa cosa se ne parla
sempre meno e lo faccio perché questo
tipo di software hanno avuto un impatto
molto forte all'interno della società e
hanno cambiato un po le abitudini e il
nostro modo di diagonale e addirittura
hanno cambiato alcuni modelli economici
degli ultimi anni
lo faccio partendo da una piccola storia
siamo nel 1991 siamo in finlandia è uno
studente di ingegneria di 22 anni ha
bisogno di risolvere un problema
lui voleva lavorare ai suoi esercizi che
faceva a scuola a casa
siamo nel 91 e quindi non ci sono gli
smartphone i personal computer sono
all'inizio della loro storia ed internet
si sta diffondendo il fatto è che la
scuola possedeva delle macchie molto
costose erano macchine che non è uno
accessibili alle tasche di uno studente
e allora lui decise di fare qualche cosa
di nuovo che nessuno aveva mai fatto
decise di iscriversi un sistema
operativo partendo dall'idea di un suo
professore che si chiamava in dieci anni
il download se volete andare a cercare e
un giorno mandò un messaggio nell'agosto
più o meno pochi mesi dopo aver iniziato
il suo lavoro mandò un messaggio che
diverse divenne celebre nella storia
dell'informatica e questo messaggio
faceva più o meno così erano andato ad
una community di altri programmatori
diceva ciao sono linus e ho scritto un
sistema operativo è il sistema operativo
che ha una linea di comando 15 si
possono fare delle cose però non è
completo
non sarà mai grande come altri sistemi
operativi che sono ad oggi commerciali o
già distribuiti in maniera open source e
soprattutto funziona solo sul mio
computer perché è l'unico subito potuto
provarlo io ho un hard disk di un tipo
solo ho una memoria di un tipo solo e
funziona solo con quelle in realtà le
cose non andavano proprio così
anzi l'impatto che ebbe questa cosa fu
molto diverso
linus ricevette un sacco di contributi
nel giro di qualche settimana
ci fu un attenzione addirittura
mediatica attorno al suo lavoro e il
sistema cominciò a crescere
linus chiamò il suo sistema operativo
che era quello che aveva prodotto linux
con la radice del suo nome e scelse come
loro continuino ad oggi linux giva su
circa tre quarti dei sistemi operativi
che operano il web voi usate linux
indirettamente ogni volta che accede ad
internet
cos'era successo perché è andata così
bene a linus torvalds
fino ad allora l'open source esisteva
già del sud esiste dagli anni sessanta
più o meno con qualche citazione che
abbiamo visto di starmene scorrere prima
l'open source esisteva è però il
software si faceva con una modalità un
po diversa non parlo di strumenti si
parlò anche di strumento ma soprattutto
di modi di modelli produrlo il software
era il cosiddetto modello a cattedrale
che significa che si raccolgono dei
requisiti delle funzionalità delle cose
che il
ma deve fare e poi ad una certa data
prestabilita all'inizio si rilascia
qualche cosa un prodotto che dovrebbe
essere pronto per andare a finire nelle
mani del pubblico quindi senza barche in
in un certo senso che tende alla
perfezione per quanto può essere un
primo bilancio
e in tutto questo gli operatori gli
artigiani che scrivono questo software
che sono programmatori e lo modificano
in silenzio quasi religioso linux se c'è
una cosa molto diversa lui quasi buttò
quello che aveva appena prodotto non
appena ebbe un embrione di quello che
voleva realizzare in pasto al pubblico e
il suo pubblico era un pubblico di
tecnici quindi la sua era se una
richiesta di aiuto ma anche un modo di
condividere quello che lui aveva fatto
l'open source in questo modo ha
prosperato ci sono state delle fasi
anche molto difficile dell'open source e
questo modello il modello cattedrale
se il modello bazar che era quello di
linus torvalds ha avuto dei problemi
innanzitutto la qualità del codice che
arrivava era molto diversa c'erano delle
persone brave e anche delle persone che
dovevano imparare e poi l'attenzione
mediatica era superiore al numero di
contributi che lui dice aveva quindi
c'era ancora un po di lavorarci la
comunità ci ha lavorato le aziende ci
hanno lavorato la società ci ha lavorato
e siamo arrivati finire ad avere quelle
che io definirei personalmente tre fasi
la prima fase della penske e stata dai
tecnici per i tecnici ovvero siamo tutti
professionisti che fanno lo stesso
lavoro o anche appassionati e vogliamo
migliorare il modo in cui lavoriamo
quindi iniziamo a scambiarci dei pezzi
per non dover sempre reinventare la
ruota a crearci dei piccoli standard che
sono i standard del web
che sono i sistemi con cui distribuiamo
il codice con cui raccogliamo le
impressioni su tutti che facciamo dagli
utenti
il server web in internet i protocolli
poi c'è stata una seconda fase direi che
è stata quella continua ad essere quella
dei dei programmi quindi i prodotti che
sono arrivati al pubblico ne sono già un
po più famosi è più facile che anche i
non appassionati noi tecnici li
conoscono
mi riferisco a mozilla firefox che è un
browser famosissimo mi fermi riferisco
ad android che è basato su linux
mi riferisco a openoffice che oggi è
river office e software di questo genere
chimps se vogliamo wordpress per chi ha
un sito personale e magari ha sentito
parlare in piattaforme di blogging
e poi c'è la terza fase la terza fase
secondo me è quella un po più
interessante perché si stacca da quello
che è strettamente il mondo del software
ma in bava dall'esperienza dell'open
source da quello che è successo in
quelle ecosistemi di persone che si
scambiavano della conoscenza aperta e
con può essere né schiavano dei
meccanismi virtuosi con questo mi
riferisco a altri prodotti ad esempio
wikipedia che ci dà accesso ad un
inventario di informazioni dalla tasca
del nostro smartphone
mi riferisco ad open street map di cui
avrete modo magari anche dopo mi
riferisco a tutto il filone del crowd
funding dove le persone che non sapevano
programmare
comunque contribuivano e iniziavano dei
meccanismi virtuosi per andare ad
abilitare dei cambiamenti uno scambio
insomma tutti ecosistemi aperti
cos'è che ci ha portato fin qui
io ho identificato una cosa leggendo
nell'esperienza di quest'anni sentendo
anche altre persone parlarne e questa
cosa sono le piattaforme
l'idea qual è l'idea di tutte queste
cose che sono successe sia nell'ambito
del software che nell'ambito poi dei
prodotti e degli altri tipi di progetti
che sono venuti dopo
e lascia il tuo ecosistema libero
la conoscenza libera matrimoni dei
vincoli crea delle regole secondo la
quale le quali le persone possano
contribuire ai tuoi progetti
le piattaforme le piattaforme sono dei
sistemi tecnologici che stabiliscono una
standardizzazione culturale che
significa all'interno di una serie di
regole
voi potete fare quello che volete che
significa faccio degli esempi
twitter ha una piattaforma facebook è
una piattaforma wikipedia è una
piattaforma ci sono dei flussi dei
metodi dei modi di lavorare che voi
quando approcciate questi sistemi
imparate imparate perché la buona
piattaforma vi fa cadere dentro
l'impatto la e abbatte un posto che è il
costo di dover spiegare vicendevolmente
come si lavora insieme alla piattaforma
è è questo quindi un insieme un insieme
di regole con dei vincoli faccio un
parallelo faccio un parallelo con gli
artigiani gli artigiani sto finendo
ingressi ciò una metafora che è stata
fatta da un sociologo che si chiama
ricevesse nello sme paragona gli
artigiani della comunità linux
a quelli che c'erano nell'antica grecia
gli artigiani dell'antica grecia avevano
imposto di rilievo all'interno della
società stavano fra gli schiavi che
erano nella loro condizione la
commissione in cui era e sava tra
intestavano con i nobili quindi non
avere potere decisionale ma la società
li premiava perché avevano contribuito a
migliorare lo stato della società e dei
villaggi delle dei posti in cui
lavoravano
pensate alla metallurgia pensate alle
pelli pensate all'idraulica tutta una
serie di cose che faceva vivere le
persone un po meglio cosa dicesse n se
ne dice che gli artigiani che hanno
scritto linux ed una serie di altri
software open source e questi questi
artigiani che vengono dall'antica grecia
hanno in qualche cosa in comune
questo qualche cosa e come trattano la
conoscenza la conoscenza in entrambi gli
ecosistemi è libera di circolare ci si
spiega a vicenda quello che succede come
fare le cose e questo innesca dei
meccanismi virtuosi innesca delle fasi
di riferimento a volte con linguaggi
anche molto utili soprattutto perché se
pensate a tutti questi progetti cercati
quando voi vi trovate a dover
contribuire se l'avete mai fatto se
avete mai o se siete stati anche dei
futuri forse lo potete comprendere
quando voi vi trovate a modificare una
voce su wikipedia oppure a sistemare un
bug in un progetto open source famoso
non c'è nessuno che vi blocca voi
inviate la vostra modifica senza dover
fare il punto l'odio come se fosse una
in un'azienda senza che qualcuno validi
a priori la vostra modifica e a
posteriori qualcuno la valuta la valuta
per il lato positivo il lato negativo
ovvero la vostra modifica sarà accettata
oppure no questo è quello che è successo
in un sacco di mondi relativi all'open
source e più in generale
questo succede quando la conoscenza è
libera di di espandersi per cui i modi
per amministrare la conoscenza delle
discipline quello che voglio dire oggi
sono due ci sono gli ecosistemi di
conoscenza aperti che sono questi che
abbiamo visto che sono qua imprevedibili
che creano prodotti che magari
all'inizio sono lenti sono imperfetti
sono pieni di problemi ma a un certo
punto secondo la legge di linus ad
esempio una quantità di occhi
sufficiente è sufficiente per risolvere
tutti i bug che ci sono in
quell'applicazione questo si estende
anche a wikipedia
se volete se volete fare un parallelo e
l'altro sistema l'altro è che il sistema
di conoscenza e quello ha chiuso pensate
per esempio ai burocrati
pensate a tutti quei processi in cui a
priori si stabiliscono
delle date degli obiettivi dei citati si
fanno delle analisi sono due modi di
lavorare bene tutto diversi
e io però direi che al giorno d'oggi nel
per quanto riguarda quello che è
accaduto finora nel mondo della
conoscenza dei prodotti legati alla
conoscenza è il codice aperto quindi gli
ecosistemi di conoscenza aperti il
codice aperto intestato pervasivo
l'aprire le proprie ricette è stata una
cosa pervasiva per un sacco di di
aziende dei sistemi e di progetti
addirittura delle aziende che fondano il
proprio il proprio mercato sul segreto
industriale su un nome elevato rivelare
mai il proprio codice si sono trovate ad
abbracciare l'open source in maniera
forse lino di spendendo un sacco di
soldi in marketing anche per fare questo
le rosse in realtà aveva già molto
positivo quando una decina di anni dopo
il suo progetto già le aziende potevano
capire che quella cosa era interessante
leggete che nel 99 la prima azienda che
usò linux e nei forni fece il suo
business vedat appena si quotò
rimborsabile triplicate il valore delle
proprie azioni
era il 99 nello stesso anno ibm un'altra
azienda che faceva informatica spese un
miliardo di dollari solo nel
miglioramento e nella formazione di
linux
bene perché a riporto qui perché io
credo che l'open source e ciò che ne è
venuto dopo tutte quelle cose che hanno
imparato dall open source dal mondo del
software di questi piccoli artigiani che
volevano migliorare la propria
condizione e scambiarsi delle
informazioni
inventare sempre la ruota abbiamo avuto
veramente un impatto forte all'interno
della società noi in tasca abbiamo il
telefono con il quale possiamo accedere
a qualsiasi tipo di informazione
lo facciamo passando da una rete
telefonica che ha dell'istat è costruita
su degli standard aperti lo facciamo su
una rete internet che è costruita dagli
standard aperti attraverso dei server
operati da software open source e magari
andiamo addirittura su wikipedia
ora io non so se sia iniziata una nuova
fase
poi mi stacco in porto e chiudo dal
mondo dell'informatica
però ho notato una cosa le persone che
hanno fatto e hanno costruito progetti
open source di successo hanno fatto due
cose la prima è migliorare la propria
condizione
i programmatori più famosi di questo
mondo sono molto benestanti
la seconda è stato restituire agli
ecosistemi di conoscenza quello che
avevano creato quello che avevano
imparato per cui si si sono
personalmente arricchiti ma hanno anche
migliorato l'ecosistema sociale nel
quale vanno inseriti e direi nel 2017 il
nostro modo di vivere quasi tutto se
trovi terziario che lavora davanti un
computer
il novecento è stato dominato da un
metodo produttivo che si che si sfilava
al marxismo al capitalismo
se però facciamo un salto indietro di un
centinaio di anni andiamo nell'ottocento
troviamo un compendio molto molto molto
basso di cui non voglio parlare a chi
voglio diffondere nei di socialismo di
né di marxismo che si chiama socialismo
che vede dei pensatori come carlo
rosselli in italia o sensi monitoraggi
tutte queste persone mettevano in
contrapposizione le stesse due cose che
forse questo tipo di progetti ha visto
realizzarsi la contrapposizione tra il
non esaurire completamente le risorse
trattarle e restituirle alla comunità e
dall'altra parte personalmente fare il
successo di un'azienda è successo di una
persona
ora io non so come questa
contrapposizione forte che io definirei
in un certo senso socialismo liberista
applicato a questi progetti sia stata
possibile socialismo e l'interista sono
due parole fortemente in
contrapposizione se ci pensate però in
qualche modo è successo così e io non lo
so se questa è la definizione giusta o
se siamo all'interno in coda di una fase
credo che imparando dalla storia l'open
source sia una fase non sia una moda i
cicli della storia si ripetono come
quegli artigiani questo
e qualcosa nel quale stiamo passando
attraverso però vi posso dire due cose
la prima è che negli anni 60
nessuna azienda di questo mondo si
sarebbe mai fatta fregio di rivelare con
sos e riletto industriale le ricette dei
propri prodotti
il codice nel nostro caso la seconda è
che di open source non si parla
praticamente più ci sono pochi eventi
come questo dove si parla di open source
e non è perché lo penso sia meno
importante sia sparito non se ne fanno
anche perché oggi lo diamo per scontato
è entrato prede cotte nel dna di aziende
di progetti di imprese ed è un modo per
fare esattamente